science has made the world a better
place to deny that I think is ridiculous
people in this audience are alive who
would not be alive 100 years ago if we W
for Science and more people eat and are
able to survive and live a higher
quality of life because of science we
can do amazing things we can communicate
around the world we can experience
things we could never experience and of
course along with technology can come
problems and how we address that is
unfortunately not a scientific question
it's a political question so the
politics of dealing with these questions
as much the Technologies of dealing with
climate change are much easier to
consider than the politics of
implementing it